the Obamas left the White House almost
two years ago can you believe it but
they don't want you to forget how
awesome they were excuse me our well
with Michelle's current rock star like
book tour the pair's global speechifying
and their deep ties to Hollywood celebs
they're hard to avoid last night Barack
Obama visited the Baker Institute in
Houston Texas and he came off as a man
who was obsessed with himself and
obsessed with taking credit for another
guy's Trump's success and by the way
American energy production you wouldn't
always know it but you know it went up
every year I was president and you know
that whole suddenly America's like the
biggest oil producer and the biggest get
that was me people I just want you to
sometimes you go to Wall Street and
folks would be grumbling about
anti-business I said and you checked
where your stocks were when I came in
office where they're now what what are
you talking what are you complaining
about just say thank you please no thank
you
Obama's efforts at legacy building
notwithstanding the difference between
the two president's economic records is
stark
Andy puckster fast-food exec and one
time trump Labor Secretary nominee wrote
a fantastic piece in yesterday's Wall
Street Journal he compared the end of
the Obama economy with the beginning of
the Trump economy
check this out GDP growth staggered
along at 1.5 percent in mr. Obama's
final six full quarters in office but
growth doubled to 3 percent during mr.
Trump's first six full quarters the
increase in jobs openings over mr.
Trump's first 21 months has averaged an
impressive 75,000 a month but over mr.
Obama's last 20 months in office the
number of job openings increased an
average of 900 a month well during mr.
Obama's last 21 months the number of
employed Americans increased up at an
average of 150 7,000 a month
but under mr. Trump the increase is
accelerated to two hundred and fourteen
thousand a month a whopping 36% of
improvement unbelievable on top of that
we all know other facts right
they've been record low african-american
Latino unemployment credible rise in
small business applications and totally
jacked up consumer confidence you get
the point
Obama's pathetic attempt to take credit
for the fruits of his successors
policies while Obama criticizes most of
those very same policies
she's patently ridiculous and that's not
the only thing by the way that doesn't
wash in Obama land Michelle and I and
our girls we came out intact in a and
and what I mean by that is that the core
values that we brought into the office
pretty homespun values you know tell the
truth and you know try to see the other
person's point of view and treat people
kindly and with respect with respect
excuse me if I laugh like all the
respect his administration and he
himself showed for any obama critic let
me just make this point john because
we're not campaigning any the election
is over they had suspicions about
whether government should make sure that
kids in poverty are getting enough to
eat
thank you much how much better off our
country would be if Republican
politicians have spent years precisely
trying to scare voters that's all
Republicans did that was that was the
nice stuff he said by the way and as far
as his homespun values that he bragged
about last night values like I don't
know telling the truth if you like your
doctor you will be able to keep your
doctor period if you like your health
care plan you will be able to keep your
health care plan period and Solyndra is
gonna be a really good investment but
five hundred million dollars down the
tubes well Obama
is spending his non-retirement pining
away let's face it for that bygone era
when liberals dominated all media
platforms and whether it was Cronkite or
Brinkley or what-have-you there was a
common set of facts a baseline around
which both parties had to adapt and
respond to and by the time I take office
what you increasingly have is a a media
environment in which if you are a Fox
News viewer you have an entirely
different reality than if you are a New
York Times reader oh yeah it is entirely
different we see the world as it is
while the New York Times and certain
other networks sell their own version of
reality and oftentimes that version of
reality is one where all those flyover
people in the middle of the country they
kind of just fade away
to be replaced by hipper cooler
progressives and maybe some socialist
urbanites well some of us on talk radio
and the president despises talk radio we
actually speak with the so-called
deplorable z-- every day we actually saw
Trump's victory coming while the so
called erudite said who live and die by
every headline of the old gray lady were
confident right up until the end that
Hillary Clinton was gonna win but the
real reason Obama detests Fox talk radio
pretty much any conservative website is
because he prefers life kind of the way
it was or is today on college campuses
well you know where diversity of thought
is largely non-existent and we're
violators of vague community standards
are punished or shunned and meanwhile
we're sycophants and toadies certain
liberal ideals or people enjoy special
privileges and nonstop accolades from
professors for their courage and their
insight well guess what millions of
Americans are actually glad either
didn't even go to university or they're
glad that they live now in something
called the real world they actually
graduated and they prefer news source
and commentary where their own values
are not under constant assault and
ridicule by the so called elites but
Barack Obama kind of has contempt for a
lot of those values at least a lot of
the values you and I hold dear and he
doesn't have all that much respect for
any American who doesn't think like he
does now this line last night made it
clear he hasn't learned much of anything
since his snide bitter clinger comments
quickly enough to the the fact that
there were people being left behind and
that frustrations were going to flare up
in those environments you then start
getting a different kind of politics you
start getting to politics based on a
nationalism
that's not pride in country but hatred
for somebody on the other side of the
border okay so let me get this straight
anyone who supported Donald Trump
especially as immigration policy border
enforcement and the like is basically a
racist a xenophobic bigot or maybe
you're just run-of-the-mill stupid hick
if he has an interesting way of kind of
saying doesn't come out and say it but
that's you know you don't have to be
Einstein to read between the lines there
in at bottom it's a negative and cynical
view of about half of the American
population currently and you know when
you think about that dark cynical view
of America you know what it reminds me
of the government gives in the drugs
feels bigger prisons there's a
three-strike law and then wants us to
sing god bless america no no
I don't think that my church is actually
particularly controversial to member of
the United Church of Christ well I guess
you can take the man out of Reverend
Wright's church but you can't take
Jeremiah Wright's mindset sometimes out
of the man beneath all the polish and
the smooth talk and the kind of side
jokes Obama still can't see that there
are substantive reasons why not everyone
loves them maybe not as much as people
like Beyonce and jay-z do and that's the
angle